here we go see oh there you are now are
you using two cameras for this I'm using
logy captures like you have both at the
same time me too
you know leve Rosman was shocked when I
told him that I didn't need two cameras
if I use logic capture do you ever have
an issue though with a logic capture
like lagging out a little bit in your
audio I'm not that I'm aware of
interesting okay so not surprised that I
have a technical issue that other people
don't so III don't want it looked like
you're now doing some politic stuff well
I was I was watching the press
conference as well I mean it's that I've
always really been interested in
politics but you know how it is if
you're not keeping up with everything
you're gonna miss a lot of information
so I'm just trying to catch up again but
if you don't mind can ask a little bit
about your thoughts on the press
conference before we get started with
the chest well this was a brand new
Trump this was a serious Trump this was
taking it seriously Trump it's gonna get
worse before it gets better and he
believes in masks and bla bla bla bla
bla but this is like the this is
desperation basically I mean this would
have been reasonable On February 6th
right and so like now we have two
million active cases now he's been
getting shamed for six months for not
wearing the mask now he's losing to
Biden by 15 in some polls so they came
up with the idea of go up there and be
used that serious voice that he has
which sometimes he can hold together and
so on it but it's just it's it's none of
it reeks to me is genuine it just seems
like desperation yeah it seemed like he
was way more reasonable in this press
conference than anything you read about
him and his views so actually this was
the first one I watched all the way
through and I was really surprised yes
it's shocking it shocked but it's not
real you know and the way you could see
it come out was when he started getting
asked questions if the question wasn't
like gushing praise then he started to
get agitated and you know I mean I don't
want a guy I don't want to upset your
chat I don't know what
going on over there and you know you can
feel free to say whatever opinion you
have here what I've been trying to
explain over and over to my chat here is
like we're not here to attack anyone for
their political views whatsoever right
all views are welcome some happen to be
wrong and I think it's important to
mention those nobody Trump Trump keeps
you know on this stuff where he'll say
we have the lowest mortality Raiders
right like that and it's like well hold
on a second then he put up a screen a
graph that said case fatality rate all
that tells you is out of the positive
cases how many people are dying and you
can mess with that by doing more tests
or doing fewer tests you really want to
look at deaths per capita and the u.s.
is tenth and deaths per capita and you
you know anybody who wants to can go to
world amador info and just sort the
countries by deaths per capita it's like
you don't have to take my word for it in
fact you shouldn't you should you should
find it for yourself it's not so good
when it comes to the mortality rate here
it's actually quite bad right we
actually looked at one of the graphs
that he showed up and in the subtitle it
says during an outbreak of a pandemic
the CFR is a poor measure of the
mortality risk of the disease the case
fatality rate right and and of course
you know what's crazy about that dad
that's not literally wrong the problem
is that when you have different degree
if you're comparing one country to
another you can't compare the death rate
by looking at a metric that depends on
how much testing you're doing like does
that make sense yeah no that makes a lot
of sense so in terms of the data that he
decided to show I mean it seemed like
you're just going for the narrative to
try and convince you know his political
base that he did a good job in his
administration with kovat right well I
don't know that he's trying to yes but I
think he's trying to convince people
that are not in his base his base is
voting for him no matter what I mean
they think he's done a great job so he
doesn't need to convince them of
anything he's trying to convince other
people who have been seeing him not take
this seriously since day one that he's
now taking it seriously that's the game
right now because it's like Democrats
are basically not going to vote for him
Republicans are independents have swung
to Biden hugely so he needs them
needs them to come over interesting so
so do you think what he's doing now is
an effective tactic I think it's too
little too late I mean I think at this
point it's like he the guy needs to cure
cancer you know I think what's more
likely I think what's more likely to
work is they try like we're
investigating hunter Biden for something
and try to do like the sort of smear
investigation or suppress voting or
something like that I mean at this point
it's like if we got a vaccine in the
next few months which would be amazing
it wouldn't be because of Trump I mean
he'll try to take credit for it but it
might be too little too late you have to
remember voting starts in six weeks
North Carolina and two other states in
six weeks they start early voting and
absentee so it's like the election is
now basically right yeah I saw that you
were you're tweeting about how he messed
it up so poorly that like you're afraid
of some of the smear tactics he might
end up using I'm afraid of a few things
I mean one it's like I oh I never want
to overestimate the intelligence of
voters and some people might actually
fall for him saying like hey I did X or
Y like you know if Oxford University in
England gets a vaccine Trump will take
credit for it and some people might
actually be dumb enough to think Trump
had anything to do with that which is
crazy but then you know he was asked the
other day will you leave if you will you
accept the results if you lose in
November and he didn't say yeah he was
like well yeah you know I mean I've got
to see the results first then I'll tell
you if I accept them like that makes me
worried that he'll say on November 4th
it was rigged and then some of his
supporters will go out with guns and
it'll get very ugly right we saw him say
that during the debates we saw him say
that during the Chris Wallace interview
yeah it's it's a little intimidating to
hear I guess I'm just curious about your
take on on one more question so let's
say that Biden does get elected um how
much of a difference do you think he's
gonna be able to make in terms of how
the u.s. is dealing with kovat so the
it's a really good question because it
takes a while to see the effects so it's
a disaster now
because on January 20th we had our first
positive test and South Korea had its
first positive test South Korea
developed the test and they isolated
people with symptoms etc etc etc we
didn't write even into March Trump was
saying it's gonna go away like a miracle
15 cases will be 0 etc etc so if biden
takes over in november and he doesn't
get sworn in until january you really
won't see the effects of what biden is
doing until probably late march i mean
it's crazy but that's the reality the
excuse me the advantage of biden would
be during the transition period
hopefully he would actually regain the
respect of some other countries and
start working together with other
countries in a way that's not happening
and then when if and when he was
inaugurated then you would maybe see us
get to the testing level that we need
but these are gonna be slow changes fair
enough well thank you so much for for
answering some of these questions it's
really refreshing to hear your
perspective and as i told you i think on
twitter
i've been listening to to a lot of your
podcasts ever since i saw that your
announcement pogchamp thank you i
appreciate that yeah i think it's great
you're doing some of this stuff i mean
it's certainly at some risk i mean i
know that when non-political streamers
get into politics it can get very ugly
right i mean you're you're doing
political content every day how did you
even get into being a political youtuber
um that's a good you know get into it i
don't know i can't get out but i don't
remember exactly how i got in i had a
podcast and a community radio show years
ago and just started filming it and
putting it on youtube it sort of just
started like on a whim and youtube is a
huge platform for us now and i've only
been on twitch for like nine months now
and that's a whole new world for me as
well but i yeah youtube we've been on
for a long time and it just started by
actually Genki ogor from the young turks
told me youtube could be big put some
cameras in the radio station and start
filming your show okay well yeah and a
chat for those of you who do have
questions on his podcast he actually
takes calls from viewers as well
was really interesting way to ask and
are you doing political streams on
Twitch now as well is there anywhere
embers can come okay oh yeah well if
some of the mods can can link his
channel that would be very appreciated
just so people know where to find David
and speaking of other cool things you do
with your channel I saw that you host
Chad's tournaments for your listeners
we've done three yet I have a shockingly
I have a bunch of I mean I don't maybe
it's not shocking I have a bunch of
chess players in my audience so even
though I'm terrible I found that I'll
get like sometimes 700 people to play in
my tournament Eric Rosen has won two of
the three tournaments and then the third
one he just didn't play in so it's not
like he lost he just didn't play that
day no but people seem to like it
and in those tournaments I don't know
that we've had a couple a couple titled
players play but shockingly high number
of players like 2100 and above in my
audience I mean honestly they may not
really be in my audience they may just
be hearing about the tournament
somewhere else and just saying I'll play
got it okay no that makes sense
so for today's lesson I was thinking
about what might be helpful is I can
match you up against somebody who has
similar rating to you and and from what
I saw based on your chest comm and your
Leach sou around 1,100 right sure yeah
yeah and we could play a longer format
game and then we keep talk about the
plans together and I think that's been
very helpful from some of the past
lessons and then I'll notice your style
a little bit more so I could give some
more specific pointers as well that's
huge okay cool let me just quickly set
set it up so the scene is a little
better
all right now it is possible that I may
not improve like there may be something
in my brain we're like chess is just not
something I can get any better at uh
well you know what I mean I doubt that I
doubt that based on you know the success
of how you're able to do political
commentary and how good you are to
explaining things but what I'm saying
even you know even if you lose in
pogchamp i'm not gonna blame you too
much for it i love it
and are you streaming on twitch right
now as well yes I am okay perfect cool
um so so sorry let me turn off GPS it's
distracting me just give me like a two
minutes and I will get it ready also why
did I should I be telling you sort of
like the approaches that I have so far
as white and black just to contextualise
at all yeah exactly and we'll do that
when you start when you start playing
the game as oh god okay but if you want
to talk generally about like your ear
style down what you say your weaknesses
are it can definitely help I guess the
question is weed uses I don't think we
have time for I'll see you what mistakes
we think are easiest to prepare for okay
and I feel like you're pretty busy you
probably don't have that much time to
even you know study chess and do stuff
like no I'm taking this I just need
someone to tell me where the focus
should be but I want to take this
seriously actually okay perfect so I
will definitely be able to do that I'm
just finding a 1200 rated sub who we can
play against okay and your twitch is
David packing right yeah yes okay
perfect so for the for the sub who I
hear you up with and sub if you're
listening now also um we're we're gonna
be we're gonna be talking I'm gonna be
adding time so that we can actually you
know be able to discuss the plan so
don't be upset if you lose whatever it
is okay let's just find somebody
oh now I also I've heard reports that
there's this guy some people know him as
destiny I know him as Steven Kenneth
destiny been out of a second that you've
done some stuff with him yeah we've done
some chest streams do you guys get along
or oh we get along super well yeah no no
we get along there's pictures of us
hugging on my Instagram you know and I'm
not joking they're literally there's
pictures of us hugging on my Instagram
and it's all great pre coronavirus
obviously but it's but there's been a
weird thing because there's this other
streamer Hassan and I guess Hassan and
Steven Kenneth they're not getting along
that well and I've like opted out of
picking sides and it's just it's complex
it's very because they didn't one of the
Young Turks get you into streaming into
streaming oh yeah
so yes Shawn's Uncle genk got me into
YouTube that is true but that was so
long ago you know I think Jack I think
Hassan was was in elementary school at
the time or something like that got it
okay there's some connection there okay
the sub I was about to pair you up with
just just left so um separate can you
put your username in the chat I'm gonna
pair you up with somebody a little bit
stronger but we're playing as a team so
I think it'll be fine separate can you
put your username in the chat I want to
put a sub who I trust won't you know I'm
turned on their computer got it okay
cool yeah so so take your time with this
explain explain your thought process out
loud and I'll basically comment if I
think there's something you're missing
okay when you when you say your thoughts
a lot it actually really helps me to see
what you're missing okay okay well I
mean I'm about to pair you up are you oh
I'm just like I'm special yeah you are
yep there we go all right people people
in your chat seems to know I once went
to dinner with Stephen Kenneth and Hasan
and that's this it was great it was
actually they used to be really good
friends so um I actually though that
probably would be pleasant but
unfortunately
destiny is done in pogchamp but he's
interested in chests like you guys
should you a practice match because your
similar rating that's actually a good
idea yeah I think it'd be fun to watch
okay so I laid a four and then as white
I have been dabbling in the Vienna so
I'll play Knight to c3 sounds good I
think at one thousand um you don't have
whatever opening theory you have unless
like you you're getting a really bad
position from the start if you're
remembering the basics like getting the
center developing your pieces nice
before Bishop canceling that's as much
as you should need to know okay and when
you're playing somebody specifically so
you know you're gonna be playing against
say 2d Cinderella and pogchamp so then
we could you know prepared generally
against what she plays right yeah that's
a whole other thing which is people can
probably tell from my practic coaching
what are the openings I go for so I
should really have shadow training
seriously that's what you should do I've
been informed as a coach to not give
specific lines to my students nothing I
did it Wow okay well I won't even ask I
don't know so usually then I will play
in this position in this opening Bishop
to c4 yep very cooling way to start off
the opening here I'm guessing it'll get
more interesting towards the middle game
that's where I find that a lot of new
players start to struggle once they've
moved on with the basics and they
actually have to come up with a plan but
it's a lot more variant a lot more
dependent on how the position is right
okay here typically I would play d3
mm-hmm so far so good
he's taking his time here he seems like
he's a little concerned no supper has
been playing chess for a long time
actually he was he was on on chest which
back in like 2017 before it was big hmm
yeah okay so now I often will play f4
okay you go you go for f4
yeah um have you have you always played
that have you tried anything else not
I've not really tried I don't have that
much experience with with the Vienna so
no I've not really to go for this
generally got it cuz sf4 seems like a
harder line to play but you know what
let's see how you've been playing it
let's see how you can playing it I think
Knight f3 is more beginner friendly
mostly because whenever you're pushing
pawns next to your King it's gonna be a
little bit more dangerous okay yeah
usually often my next move here would be
Knight 2 & 3 um you did let me give you
this line yeah we went over this that
makes sense if you if you taught you the
theory for it it's fine um I've always
been a little bit more careful when I
usually start with students just because
there's certain things that people are
more likely to fall for but if you know
the theory that's okay if you're willing
to put in the work and learn the theory
okay so now with the bishop on before I
don't I don't know that I changed my
plan necessarily I think I'd probably
still play Knight to f3 yes that works
Knight f3 92 they both look fine here to
me in terms of just developing your
knight and trying to castle as quickly
as possible okay okay and so so now I
actually am unsure about should I just
Castle because I have the opportunity or
should I maybe try to develop the
dark-squared bishop
usually I would try to castle right away
the only caveat I would say is if you
ever if there's a threat that you need
to defend like say if you castle you're
worried about him doubling pawns by
taking your knight and having a to see
pawns doubled but that doesn't seem like
much of a concern here because he's
trading off his Bishop pair and you'll
be able to support d4 in the future all
right so I'll castle yeah looks good
so I imagine he might want to castle
here as well I'm curious what your plan
is gonna be after you're finished with
development here well I think I mean
generally speaking if he castles I'd
probably start advancing my G and H
ponds but maybe first I would move the
dark-squared bishop moving the
dark-squared bishop makes a lot of sense
to me this is not a line that I know
theoretically but in terms of basic
opening principles it looks good I think
the only thing you need to be careful of
is if there was anything tricky with
Bishop c5 if you bring your king to h1
you can try playing something like
Knight g4 and putting pressure on f2 but
that doesn't seem like too much of a
concern here so I don't see any risk
with continuing to develop your bishop
okay now I mean I guess the most natural
move to me seems to bring the bishop to
d2 although I guess III is an option I
guess I'd be thinking about whether the
e-file might open and whether maybe I'd
ultimately want to put my rook on the
e-file but I guess I just am NOT able to
see that far ahead right now if you play
Bishop III he's going to get Knight g4
with tempo so if you're going to play
the Vienna because your King is a little
bit more open and I guess even in other
lines they could play Knight g4 that's
always a move you want to keep an eye
out for because you don't want to give
up your bishop here right away
got it three yeah I like you two as well
and I move like h3 you already pushed
your ass pawn so it's kind of weakening
the Kings side of it okay so yeah but
Bishop d2 I like there is one
technicality here if he ever takes on f4
he's gonna make you move your Bishop
twice so it'll be as if you lost a tempo
say if you would have left your Bishop
on c1 and he would have taken earlier
then you would have done it in one move
right um but it's
it's honestly not a big deal and I know
I'm already thinking about playing f5 if
given the opportunity yeah I mean s5 and
then just pushing the pants towards the
king yeah and this is also part of Levy
his opening course that he did with you
now it's more sort of just I think
actually f4 f5 was more something that I
was pushing for and he had warned me
about some specific situations where it
would not be good right which I don't
now remember that's all right
I think you can also play F takes e5 in
certain lines and play a more solid
position I think f5 if you would look at
it with a the computer which honestly
you you shouldn't even be doing it might
not like as much because it's weakening
if you don't have an immediate immediate
attack on your opponent but I think for
beginners it might be hard for them to
defend against so they you know there's
benefits and drawbacks to it now there
was some line where if I take on e5 and
then black takes back on e5 and then I
take on f7 there was no that's a
different than no no that's when the
night is on g4 whether I can get a fork
that can work but that's it you mean
your night is on g5 looking towards f7
g5 no I'm sorry with blacks no you know
what that's a completely different
position that has nothing to do with
this ok no worries so let's respond to
the Bishop e6 move history to move what
would you go for here maybe d5 d5 he
could go for d5 but I think when you try
to go for his Bishop takes e4 and D
takes e4 and he would ruin your pawn
structure a little bit ok so that's what
you actually have to reply to so
certainly I mean I can take the bishop
then would be recaptured with the pawn
and then I don't know what that does for
me necessarily I like the way you're
thinking through this because
doesn't necessarily give you a good
position but you have to deal with the
threat because that's gonna be more of
an equal position for you if you take on
e6 but if you let him take on c4 you
have to take back with your deep on then
it's gonna be a better position for him
so this is more of a reactive move here
you can either take the bishop like you
said or play Bishop b3 because if you
are going to get doubled pawns and you
take with the apon at least you're
opening up your a file and it's usually
worth it that was going to be my thought
which is playing playing the bishop back
to b3 yeah so so that's the playing
style think both Bishop b3 and Bishop
takes e6 are good options here I'm gonna
play back okay let's do that and this is
a very common plan you can try whenever
your bishop is attacked just make sure
that you think about what your pawn
structure is going to look like after
your opponent goes for the exchange got
it yeah the the vienna is is interesting
because it could be in a very aggressive
opening but also if you play it with
something like f k c5 it could be very
solid and one of those slow play styles
right and if I'm going too fast or
something is confusing please let me
know and I'll okay yeah yeah so far so
good
all right
now should I be preemptively trying to
get the King off of that diagonal to
eliminate the possibility of some checks
coming forward oh I'm really impressed
you even thought of that at a thousand
rating from commentating on the previous
pogchamp Sal OTT of people would miss
things like that yeah I think King h1 is
definitely a move you want to consider
in positions like this but only if say
it's it's very slow like if you play
something like defy that's an explosive
move you should try to think of what the
threat from this move is if there's any
weaknesses because he played it but if
you played something slow say like a six
then you could have played king h1 right
yeah so in this case I'm starting to
look and so I've got my pawn and my
knight and my bishop pointed at d5
he's got the Queen a bishop and a knight
so is that a square that I would want to
take on I mean I'm immediately forking
the knight and the bishop but I'm not
sure that in the end I really come out
ahead yes so a good way to think about
calculations is if you have the equal
amount of attackers so the finish of the
knight end the pawn as the defender is
Knight Bishop and Queen you'll just be
trading material here assuming of course
that you don't take with a pawn and he
takes with a queen assuming he takes
back with material like a bishop and
then you take back with the bishop so
then it would just be about thinking
what the position looks like after that
entire exchange yeah exactly and so
whenever you're considering whenever he
offers a trade you can you have the
three options right you can sit you can
take or you can try to get away from the
trade can't get her away from the trade
here you could sit or do another move or
you could take so so make sure you
consider all of the options because
sometimes when somebody offers you a
trade a lot of players will get really
tunnel vision and they'll only be
focused on trying to just take it back
yeah I mean I I'm thinking of whether
here I would want to play f5 because
then the bishop either has to block the
Queen on d7 or completely get back to
the eighth-ranked and neither seems
particularly good
[ __ ] f5 f5 is a good move um I think you
should go for it because it was your
original plan the other thing that would
have been important to see here is that
when he pushed d5 he stopped defending
his pawn on e5 ah so I could take that I
could - yes exactly so that was a small
tactic that was overlooked but f5 in the
way you explained the plan is also very
strong so I think we should go for that
all right let's do it yeah I actually do
like your idea better but we'll stick
with mine yeah see what happens yeah
exactly exactly
and often in into Vienna if your
opponent ever pushes d5 always make sure
that he protected the e5 pawn because it
will be a common blunder where you could
just take on e5 and be up material got
it yeah
so here what options would you say he
has well to either move the bishop back
or to attack something of mine of equal
value like maybe you know d4 or other
than d4 or what else could there be
I mean I guess d4 is what immediately
strikes out at me as possible
yeah d4 is definitely a move that you
should consider because he's attacking a
knight the other one could be Bishop
takes c3 if he just wants to trade off
because then he might force you to take
back now in that situation would I would
I definitely take back with my bishop in
order to avoid doubling the pawns and to
sort of have a diagonal that ends at age
8 so if he takes the knight on c3 okay
what she just did yes okay so here
whenever you have multiple options to
take a piece you should try to look at
all of them um so so here what are the
three pieces you should consider
capturing I guess upon the six yeah
or the black the bishop on c3 with
either my pawn or my bishop
right so which one looks better to you
first
well I mean my thought is if I take the
bishop on e6 mm-hmm
then I just lose that pond potentially
right now I don't have anything
defending it right although then I could
well know so I think I would leave that
there at least for now if I take with my
bishop on c3 then that bishop could
immediately be attacked with the d4
which seems maybe not the best because
then I immediately have to do something
about my bishop
so maybe doubling the pawns is worth it
in order to avoid having to immediately
retreat with the bishop I like the way
you thought through this I think
obviously as you play with more
experience you'll be able to go a little
deeper into lines so F takes c6 the
option you explained if he takes your
Bishop on d2 you have an intermediate
move meaning that you don't respond
directly to him capturing your Bishop on
d2 but you play something else first and
then you take the bishop do you see what
that move is would it be taking the pawn
on d5 forking the bishop and Knight
that's another good move to consider but
it's less forcing and it'll give him an
intermediate move in in response where
he doesn't deal with a fork but he gives
you a check on e3 first okay so the
question is if I take on e6 and then he
takes my bishop what could I do that's
more forcing well I could check the king
by taking the pawn on f7 yeah exactly
and if you do that then he has to take
back so you don't have the double pawn
and then you can recapture the bishop
okay I think I like that yeah and
honestly the way you calculated was
already extremely strong for your rating
but you know it's good when you have a
coach to just push your calculation a
little bit further just so you get into
that habit of doing yeah all right let's
go for it and see what happens all right
he actually she also has an intermediate
move here Bishop d4 but I thought that
one would have been pretty pretty
tricky to see and you can still deal
with it if he does it right but
intermediate moves are like the a more
advanced calculation that you always
have to kind of keep in mind when you're
going for trades or other tactics right
and if that intermediate move were to
happen I could choose to either give
away okay well hold on so that I didn't
really consider yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of variation and that's
one of the most difficult things in
calculating these lines you don't have
to look at one but each one has like
another you know set of so now do I take
the pawn on f7 because I mean then I
still have to deal with this issue of
the rook on a1 right so why don't you go
through through your options here so
usually in calculation you want to go
Brett's first then depth so like look at
all of the options first just to make
sure you're not overlooking something
that's really strong and then go deeper
into the one you think is the most
promising usually checks or captures you
go into first okay so I mean checks
would be taking the pawn on f7 you can
go here so Brett's first rook to b1
mm-hm
[Music]
and there's one more let's see taking
the pawn on d5 yes so those are the
three options and and now you can start
which which ever one you think is the
best well if I take the pawn on d5 well
let's start with with the check if I
take then the King could either move to
h8 or h7 or take the pawn or the rook
could take the pawn absolutely I don't
know that I have anything I mean I guess
if the King took I could then check the
king by taking the pawn on e5 but then I
just lose that night right makes sense
right the king takes what would be the
threat that you have to respond to next
the possibility of losing my rook right
so where would you move probably be one
yeah perfect so so that looks like I
mean if you get that deep into the line
you already
the main idea in it my other question to
you would be what is the piece count at
that point right I mean I think that
because my pawn on e6 is undefended I
either am trading upon and then rescuing
the rook or rescuing the rook and then
just losing upon so it seems I'm better
off putting the king in check by taking
that pawn first yeah you're correct you
are better taking the pawn in putting
the king in check first and the reason
for that is if you would have played
rook b1 the other line you suggested he
would have had Bishop d4 check which
basically a longer variation that he's
gonna keep your pawn but you already
found a line that is pretty good here
and I think that's a great way to start
so that you don't like sink too much
time okay all right so now I go rook b1
yes perfect and I will I will say there
there's a bit of a caveat because I know
that the time control for pogchamp is
pretty quick right you're not playing a
classical game if you're playing a
classical game you shouldn t be sitting
and seeing the end of these variations
yeah but you definitely want to be
careful to not sing too much of your
time unless it's like one of those
variations where you're gonna win
material at the end and then you do play
faster right so here it seems like my
options are I either block this check
which met with my bishop on e3 which
just loses the bishop doesn't make sense
correct I move the King to h1 or I take
the bishop with my knight right which
doesn't seem necessarily like a terrible
idea and that may be now now my opponent
has no bishops if I do that and I have
both bishops which seems maybe good
mm-hmm
but I don't know what my immediate
follow-up would meet B maybe then I
would take the pawn on d5 and I'm
pushing the well no because then he
could take with his knight and then I
take with my bishop but then I lose the
bishop to the Queen so I don't know that
I really win anything that way so yeah
so I guess here you can decide if
because both of the variations are going
to have those checks so do you want to
take his Bishop off of d4
and bring his knight to d4 or do you
prefer that his bishop stays on d4 and
blocks the Knights Square both are fine
so I think you should go for whichever
very omelet I'm gonna move the king I
like moving the king better here okay
let's go for that I actually like this
too usually because if you had the
bishop here the bishops work so well
together that it's usually worth it to
take one of the bishops right but
interestingly enough like it's Luke
bringing his knight to d4 would probably
be more annoying because he would then
put pressure on your Bishop on b3 and he
might actually take away your bishop
here right yeah one thing I'm looking at
here is my bishop on b3 being lined up
with the rook and the King obviously
with this pawn in the way and I'm trying
to think of whether there might be some
eventual way to take advantage of that
that's definitely what you should be
keeping an eye on and there's certainly
gonna be tricks there I think he's
probably gonna have to blunder or
something like that but this is a very
common position where you see your
opponent blunder just because it's so
tricky to deal with that pin and his
king is actually less safe than yours
now what about c4 so c4 your idea is you
want to open up the center because
you're putting pressure on the pin right
yeah I think c4 is definitely an
interesting option so we can consider
that after his next move with c4 one of
the tricky things is I guess if he moves
as king to h8 then it's new you're not
gonna have the pin anymore but if it
doesn't I I think your plan is actually
pretty good well that's interesting
because if the K if I go c4 and the King
moves to h8 now I'm in bed well now now
there's one more piece there bearing
down on that square but it would have
been maybe an opportunity to take the
pawn myself on d5 right because then he
has to take with his night and then he
has yet another pin yeah right okay well
not an opportunity anymore
[Music]
okay so more well hold on let's see you
have such a good position here actually
there's so many multiple plans that are
good so I guess the most forcing thing
would be to check the king with the
bishop by putting by taking the pawn on
d5 just hypothetically okay and if you
take on d5 how would he respond
probably by taking with the knight back
on d5 mm-hmm and then say you take with
the pawn out what does he do take with
the rook and would you say that that
exchange of pieces was better for you or
for him well I guess I win upon and the
night and then he wins a pawn in the
bishop right that sounds better for him
yeah it is but it is better for him just
because your Bishop on b3 is still
pretty powerful and one way to think
about bishops is related to King safety
so if you look at his King side or his
wheat lights where his weak or his dark
squares weak I don't know whether
they're weak if you do or don't have
pieces on them okay so it's actually the
the light squares that are weak because
okay basically the dark pawns are gonna
have a hard time protecting the the
square on g6 for example or the f7
square if the black pot on h6 was on h7
then g6 would be more protected so it's
usually the opposite color of where the
Kings side pawns are on you usually want
to keep that Bishop if you can as a
general rule of course it always is
dependent on the position but so let's
see if if I were to take with my pawn on
d5 and then takes back with the knight
and then I play c4 open that years to
create a discovery attack after he moves
the knight yeah but then of course the
knight can move because there would not
be a discovered check but then I could
maybe push c5 right so after c5 you have
a check and let's say his King
moves away what did you gain from that
check not that much right yeah I call
this feel-good checks because it are you
know it gives you some serotonin when
you get a move like that but often I
mean not often actually like it just
depends if you actually get something or
not from the check right yeah well I
guess another possibility would be c3
mm-hmm I'm in which case I'm guessing
the bishop would go to c5 or b6 right
but then I don't know what happens here
so um so one of the weaknesses I think
this is gonna help with plans generally
and in this position it's often helpful
to think of like what are the
differences in the position so here yes
the wheat kingside you notice that
there's that pin on the pawn there's
also a difference in pawn structure so
he has the d5 pawn and the e5 pawn and
those are called hanging pawns I mean
they're they're they're acting like
hanging pawns they'd be hanging pawns if
there isn't a pawn on c7 that just means
that they have a tough time defending
each other's because there's only two so
if you get rid of one or you make the
other one move forward then the other
one is gonna be very vulnerable so what
I'm saying with that is it's like if you
ever take on d5 then all of a sudden 85
is an isolated pawn right so there's the
possibility of maybe taking on d5 and
then rook to e1 after the Knight takes
my pawn back yeah that's that's a great
option or you could even go with your
plan of pushing c3 first if you want to
kick the bishop out and then taking on
d5 and putting pressure on e5 let's try
it and then in the india in the
intermediate we'll see what the reaction
is and if my plan gets interrupted yeah
no you're really liked your c3 plan
because it is a bit annoying to have a
bishop in the center of the board and
when you push C 3 you're controlling d4
you're controlling before you make it
harder for him to push his pawns forward
so I do like that plan nice
a lot of action here yeah I'm actually
super impressed with the way you're
thinking through this I mean it sounds
like you just switched to a different
mic that was weird
oh test hello sorry let me try to fix
that can oh I think what happened is I
muted myself to thank someone for the
sub and I just was really loud oh and I
need to fix my game I'm sorry about that
okay so one of the two moves that we had
talked about so now I'm thinking take on
d5 with the idea of rook to e1 yeah III
like that plan a lot so if you take on
e5 he's going to take with the knight
right um and then you can continue
putting pressure on d5 it's very
straightforward you're continuing with
what you started and you've you're
putting pressure on his one weakness
here I like it
alright let's do it now there's also
here the possibility if he takes back on
d5 oh well we had already talked about
me going then
d4 and our c4 in the end I don't really
gain that much right right it's tempting
it's tempting to just kick away the
night but I actually it was interesting
that you realized that c4 c5 didn't do
anything before I even said it yeah now
with the night you know with the bishop
on b6 yeah it still doesn't really
change anything about that yeah but now
you've created another imbalance in the
position and it's often about imbalances
so now he has that pawn on e5 which
technically gives him more space in the
center because he has his spawn one of
the central squares but it's an isolated
pawn and it's also a target so it helps
shape your plan here right so yeah I
mean after Knight takes d5 honestly his
position looks pretty unpleasant with
the pawn on d5 the pin the weak king
side I feel I feel a little bad for him
but Oh actually um wait I think I think
I missed a tactic here cuz after Knight
takes d5 c4 c5 does actually have a
purpose now because you were going to
discover your attack wit and also in his
Bishop so now because the bishops on b6
instead of d4 that plan would have
actually worked which is why I guess he
didn't take the d5 pawn right yeah so I
mean now I might think about taking the
e5 pawn myself with the knight
you know he moved away his defender and
that's a free pawn that you can take are
there any drawbacks if you do that I'm
potentially trading away my bishop on
the next move right but I would have
well actually it can't be on the next
move because then I would take the rook
you you could take the rook after he
takes on b3 yeah so it seems reasonable
it seems very reasonable to me it looks
like you're winning material yeah I
think I'm gonna go for that
and it's interesting because so that
variation wins but now with his bishop
on c6 after Knight takes b3 Queen takes
b3 you could even consider c4 because it
it's it's a longer line I think it's
probably not actually helpful that I'm
going into it but it's a cute line if
you want to look at that so the reason
potentially if I have to take back on b3
the reason I want to do it with the
Queen is it immediately lines it up with
the king right yes exactly
okay and and if he takes on d5 after you
take back with the Queen which might
look like a pawn
then you there's like some fun tactics
but I like your idea of just taking
material and then you could just
simplify it and try to get into a better
endgame now at some point I still at
least right now have the possibility of
this discovered check by playing d6
which right now wouldn't be useful to me
but maybe at some point in the future
would be right yeah g6 could be useful
say if he ever puts a piece on e7 and he
would be in trouble or even the threat
of pushing e6 would stop him from being
able to do some active moves right yeah
so so far so good
sure you're giving supper a run for his
rating here I'm curious what would you
say is the weakest part for you are the
most difficult between openings middle
games and end games it's it's I mean I
don't know it's kind of all of it
honestly oh in the openings it's that I
will so I should take back with the
Queen I think here yes yeah or take the
knight or the take the rook on d7 sorry
taking the rook on d7 winning material
your original plan I really liked I
think both of these are extremely strong
though okay yeah I mean in the opening
it's that I will often because of one
move that I don't recognize I'll make
just a bit mistake that puts me at an
immediate disadvantage and I can never
recover in the middle game it's usually
missing some kind of tactic and ending
up down a piece when I had an
opportunity to maybe end up up a piece
and then in the endgame
I mean the endgame is a whole other
situation I don't know yeah I feel like
most people don't really think and games
are
important when they're starting off but
sometimes people prioritize them so
little that they missed some basic ed
games yeah yeah so I'm curious what he's
gonna try to do here because you're
threatening taking his rook on d7 he
can't move his rook to e7 because of
your discovery attack he can't move his
rook to d6 which probably looks like the
best square for him now what about just
taking my pawn on d5 what would you what
would you play in return if he does
something like that what would I play I
guess you get to answer answer that now
hmm I'm not actually sure here what I
would play I mean if I played c4 then I
just lose the night right because he
can't take it now cuz he's pinned but
it's not gonna work if you play c4 cuz
you're intercepting your queen is there
any other way I could attack that rook
not that I can see
yeah I agree so you can't put pressure
on the rook but do you have any other
plans here
no none so you can you can try to
prepare attacking the rook so if you
want to play a move like c4 then you
could take care of the future threat on
your knight once he's no longer pinned
so like maybe Bishop to f4 Bishop to f4
is definitely one option but usually
when you're moving a piece for the
second time since you're in the middle
game now which try try to think of which
piece you can improve their positioning
so Daniel rook to f5 rook to f5 I guess
if you're trying to double your rook on
f1 one issue with rook to f5 is you're
actually also pinning your night because
then your knight won't be able to move
because then your rook is under attack
so you honestly I don't know if that's
wrong or not maybe there's there's a
tactic but in general try to be careful
with things like that cuz it's really
easy to miss tactics like he could just
start trying to put more pressure on
your knight in the future so maybe just
d4 then d4 yeah d4 definitely works
you're grabbing more space in the center
you're also blocking out of his bishop I
like that okay and the other move that
would have worked is rook B to e1 so if
you can move your rook from a semi open
file that isn't putting pressure on
anywhere to an open file that would have
been an improvement but efore also
improves the position of the pond so
those are two options that I like best
okay yeah
all right
oh no oh sorry I gave it away so breaks
the pin there yep
but there is a fork where I think I win
the Queen right yes yes there is a fork
I feel a little bit bad for him
wow you you kinda you kind of killed him
in this game I mean it doesn't help that
he blender it at the end but you played
super well well I mean I'm playing the
moves you're telling me all right so I
take the Queen yeah I don't think any
held here okay so now yeah now so the I
actually do have trouble sometimes
converting these into wins I have to
figure things I need to do so maybe now
I put my rook on e1 yeah I think what we
should do here is all let you play the
moves and I'll tell you after if there's
anything you miss all right that's the
move I would naturally play I'm gonna
give a bit more time so you get a chance
to try to beat you here um I actually
think sometimes when you're up material
it's even trickier because you might get
it relaxed a little bit and it just
takes one blunder for your opponent to
get chances again right but then again
you do have a queen for a night here but
in pong champs I've seen people come
back from from one Queen at some point
even for with two queens down wow I've
seen some stuff in my so now I almost
would want well no actually no that's a
bad idea because then I could lose my
bishop in the end I was gonna say rook
II to rook on e to e five and then take
back with the pawn and it's a trade but
then I lose the bishop so I don't want
to do that
c4 doesn't seem to work because then I
could just lose the pawn so when you're
up material are there any general
strategies you're familiar with that are
like
helpful I mean obviously general
strategies are helpful I freeze that
wrong are there any strategies you know
of when you're up material well to start
trading and simplifying yeah exactly
sorry I was trying to ask that without
hinting it too hard but I definitely
butchered it so that's one thing you
could try for if you think the position
is really tactical I think I need to get
my Bishop somewhere else first okay so I
might play Bishop to maybe to c1
alright repositioning the bishop so
you're saying it wasn't doing much on d2
that's my sense and it's potentially
blocking me from lining up with the
rooks my opponent's rooks if I wanted to
add a second defender okay um I I'm
curious where you're gonna put the
bishop from here or the rooks so now I'd
be thinking about rook to d1 okay and
then playing c4 so if you push c4 and he
takes d4 oh right then I'm just end up
just trading and right down a pond yeah
cuz cuz as soon as your pawn moves then
you're only gonna have one defender on
it yeah maybe a better idea was Bishop
to f4 and then rook to e7 I like that
idea a lot better yeah all right well
I'll try it now and see where it gets me
sorry my child is saying I was supposed
to not comment you're right I I'm sorry
I'm gonna wait until you make the move
yes so if if Bishop c1 rook d1 and c4
would've work dozen your pawn was
protected on d4 I think he makes some
sense because you're advancing your
pawns maybe it's not this most
straightforward plans but it would have
worked so the reason why that plan
didn't work is just because you you
overlooked a tactic which you know
happens to everybody now I wonder if at
some point there'd be an opportunity to
sacrifice the bishop on h6 I don't have
like an immediate check though I don't
know how much I really gained so if you
play Bishop takes h6 and he plays G
takes h6 would you have any follow-up
there well I guess I could play rook to
e8 check and then if I lose that rook
then I take the rook on d5 and I'm sort
of simplifying the situation almost if
you take the rook on d5 is there oh no
then I lose my queen yeah this I don't I
don't want to give the queen of way yet
right yeah you don't you don't want to
give the Queen away unless it's like a
traitor or winning tactic yeah I joke
that it's called a bow test gambit when
when you lose a queen because in rapid
chess I blender it often when I'm in
time pressure so before this rook move I
actually could have taken on h6 if takes
back with the pond then I win the knight
but now it's defended yeah exactly you
had that move since when you played
Bishop c1 I didn't want to say anything
because it you know it a tactic yeah
yeah that would have been really winning
for you another possibility would be
taking the pawn on c7 then take he would
take back with the bishop and then I
take the pawn on b7 I mean I'm losing
material but maybe it's it's okay for me
in some bigger strategic way I can
imagine what it is but yeah I mean
you're up so much material that's
something like that actually is still
winning for you and it's still fine I
feel like I would be teaching you bad
habits though to say like yeah give your
Bishop for two pawns right but you know
if you're up this much material you can
go for things like that so I'm still
leaning more towards putting the rook on
e7 okay that that's a solid move as well
I like the plan with worki seven-year
you're keeping the rook active putting
the rook on the seventh rank is one of
the best squares for the rook especially
combined with an open file so okay now I
don't want to move that bishop but I'm
inclined to may be different well why
don't you want to move the bishop
because then I think it's made right yes
exactly
just just checking yeah so I don't know
maybe I I would consider g3
[Music]
I don't know that I have too many other
ideas quite frankly I mean I could look
at Queen b1 I could look at Queen d1
I'll let you make them move and then
i'll give you my comment after I think
I'm gonna defend the bishop in a more
obvious way with g3 so I like that
you're defending the bishop I I'm
curious if you calculated this move did
you consider g5 for black here g5 yeah I
did not I I don't want to say what the
solution is in case you wouldn't have
seen it but yeah that one tricky thing
is if your piece is pinned so you can't
move it or you're gonna lose the rook on
f1 sometimes just defending the bishop
isn't enough maybe make it defending the
piece that is pinned is actually often a
better strategy right g5 I don't think
would have works cuz he had something
like work f7 but it's important to try
to make to see those yeah okay so let's
see now there's a second attacker on the
bishop but I think for now it's not
really okay actually I need to do
something about that I think so hold on
yeah take your time if he were to take
my bishop with the night and then I
would take back with my pawn and then
could take back with the rook and if I
took the rook then I'm just losing a
rook but I could play rook to e8 check
the King would have to come to H 7 and
then Queen to c2 would maybe force g6
and then what is at the end I don't know
you're calculating pretty far other
pieces do I have at that point if then
pawn to g6 I can't take the pawn
oh boy I don't know if that actually
works I think I'm gonna have to abandon
that entire line here is there a queen
sacrifice that could work
I don't know that playing c4 gets me
anything I'm just encouraging that line
that I just mentioned which I don't know
how good it is for me
maybe I should recalculate that hold on
a second so yeah I'm just not talking
cuz I want to let you be able to go
through with it
yeah so if I play something oh wait a
second maybe I reinforced that square
with rook to e4 yeah I'm gonna do that I
think maybe that's the way to go okay so
Ricky for is a fine move it's a little
bit passive what I will say is that in
the line you are actually just gonna
lose a pawn not a rook and losing a pawn
in exchange for simplifying here would
be pretty good okay but again it was it
was hard to calculate it all the way
through but the line you suggested was
actually very strong for you oh okay
yeah so now I'm thinking of could I push
g4 what about forking with my rook on e5
and then if the rook takes I take back
with my pond or even the knight now I
think I like the idea of advancing the
pawn more did you say c4 a g4 so
initially I said one one move would be
g4 okay the other would be putting my
rook on e5 and maybe forcing a trade of
rooks on that Square and then now I
actually wonder if I can just play c4 as
well
now that I have f4 sort of more locked
down maybe yeah I think I'm gonna play
c4 and also Eric Rosen who who when
you're arenas just gave this channel a
raid so so Eric you're watching the show
as well thanks so much
so I honestly really liked your rookie 5
idea trading off the rooks was great g4
was the move I didn't like because then
you're no longer protecting your before
and maybe I don't want to give them a
piece although you simplify so much you
could also win that way okay um and c4
made sense to do sometimes all of the
moves are winning because you already up
material but we'll see I assume I can
still manage to lose no matter what
obviously that's a very very humble
mindset in a much better one for being a
good player so I respect it okay so now
my rook is under attack I think now I
might go and try to trade the rooks on
e5 trying to see if there's any downside
so if the rook were to go to g5 to avoid
the trade I would take it with my bishop
if the rook went to h5 to avoid the
trade I might play g4 but then the
knight could take it but then I would be
able to take the rook on f8 so maybe
that's not so bad now what happens if we
do trade if I go to it rookie five rook
takes then I take then the knight is
attacked I think I like that I think
that that may help me I'm gonna try it
yeah great move I think this is
definitely the most straightforward way
to try to win the position okay cuz his
rook has nowhere to go yes a trade hmm
right because if the rook went to h5 and
then I played g4 I guess then the rook
could come to h4 oh wow he's trying to
be creative here okay so if I take the
rook and then the rook takes back
I don't know if that does that much for
me let me evaluate this move with the
knight now on g4 if there's any possible
Forks that I should be worried about
I love that you're thinking about
actually well so let's see if the knight
came to e3
it's forking oh wait no that's actually
not that it not big that's not a huge
concern right I just take it then so I
don't I don't see necessarily a problem
with this night that I need to
immediately deal with although if I
played h3 the knight might end up back
on f6 play a ch3 right now if I play h3
right now I just don't think it makes
any sense I think there's probably
something better
do I want to so if I force the the rook
trade on f5 then my knight my bishop is
kind of stuck because if I move it then
I'm giving away the rook on f1 so that
doesn't seem ideal what about if I play
Queen to d3 pinning that rook I think
I'm going for that although then is
there a fork I need to worry about I
don't think so
yeah I'm going for that okay so what I
what oh okay Queen t3 first interesting
I thought you're gonna take on f5 first
one of the things you missed here is
Knight takes e5 so basically the me what
am i doing I understand why you missed
that and actually it's actually not like
it's easier to miss that than you think
because once you start getting in deep
into variations you forget the original
motivation behind his move right which
it's always good to try to cycle back
and just be like wait what it is you
know threaten again so now I really I
mean okay I can take the knight with the
pawn I can take the knight with my
bishop
but then the oh I don't know that I want
to do that because then I think I could
have a problem on f1
I could play g4 and the rook actually
can't move but then my queen is under
attack so obviously that would be a
major problem wait a second if I take
with the bishop oh right the nut the
rook is pinned okay though because
otherwise I it's getting very very ugly
I think I take with the bishop here I
think I'm gonna go for that right yeah
the key was to see that his rook is
pinned and that he can't take on f1 yeah
perfect okay so now the rook is no
longer pinned so now if I take the rook
and takes back with the rook then I
probably play g4 if I play g4 now the
rook could take my rook on f1 and then
if I take with the Queen then I just
lose the Queen so that doesn't seem good
right oh let me flow ups a lot at a time
no no I'm fixing it sorry my bad just
just to get you a little nervous you
know to have more of a competitive
environment like pogchamp maybe I move
my king maybe I add a defender to f1
with my king that's a possibility or
also looking at c5 that really just
pushes the bishop I guess somewhere else
not that many options for it this is all
of a sudden getting a little more
difficult than I thought yeah it's still
tricky you have to be careful
do I want to take the rook because if I
take the rook and the rook comes back
then I'm it's just the trade then I
could play g4 and if the pawn takes back
then the pawn is pinned and the rook is
kind of blocked I think I'm taking with
the rook yeah I think this was the best
move and I think it's also simpler to
just remember you want to keep trading
pieces here but but the move with King
g2 would have actually been really bad
because after he would have taken on f1
Queen takes rook takes King takes he
would have given up two rooks for a
queen and a rook
so that would have been a better
position for him okay all right
so now I guess my top choices that I see
would be g4 or C 5 C 5 I mean I'm
advancing upon but the bishop gets out
of the way I don't know that I'd do that
much for myself although it would well
depending on where the bishop goes maybe
c7 would be hanging but I don't know
that it's my primary strategy right now
so what is your primary strategy right
now I guess it's to try to put the rook
in a more problematic situation and if
the rooks in a more problematic
situation watch what would your
advantage be there my queen is still
lined up with the king okay and your
queen is lined up with the king so you
think you'd be able to get some kind of
attack potentially although I couldn't
tell you what it would be got it I'm
just clarifying your plan here I'm still
not not gonna comment until after you
move I don't want to move the D pawn
because right now it's defending the
bishop mm-hmm
maybe maybe I just start moving the H
pawn although I'm not sure exactly to
where I think I'm gonna go with h3 got
it so I mean H h3 is is kind of a
passive move here yeah I'm still not
gonna tell you certain plans cuz I don't
want to spoil this game saw I'll
continue listening to how you're
thinking through this but I'm taking a
couple notes - I'm thinking g4 would be
a possibility next okay so to push his
King away his rook away yeah I'm curious
I'm curious to see after g4 what what
the plan is after I carry as York I
think maybe if the rook went away then I
would play c5 and keep advancing that
way so why do you have to kick the rook
out to play c5 I'm not I'm not saying g4
is a wrong move at all I'm just curious
why I guess I don't first I guess I
don't
this could get ugly
actually like he's managed to get some
material back here yeah and it can be
tricky cuz this rook versus a queen here
do you know how to actually it's very
unlikely to happen but king and queen
versus king and rook endgame now makes
sense I think that you I do I mean it
ends with me losing is how it ends
no I'll ease draw it come on
are there any end games you've studied
like King and pawn versus King
rook and King versus King rook and king
versus game got it yeah okay
he's taking his time here um separate
you're still around right I I think he
is he's probably just trying to increase
his chances yeah I'm thinking g4 doesn't
really do much for me I I I agree I
think I like your idea of it attacking
his his King but I just don't see the
continuation after g4 right and so you
have the two plans here you're up
material you're either gonna go for an
attack or you're going to win more
material or you're gonna simplify right
so okay I'm still thinking of c5 and h4
I mean just to continue advancing now
that the bishop is not under attack
d5 would be a possibility although I
don't know that it really makes that
much sense I guess I might play c5 okay
so if I play c5 and the bishop goes back
to a7 well I still can't take the pawn
on c7 because it's defended by the rook
so that even that that was originally a
reason to even play c5 and I don't know
that it does that much for me right now
and also if you prefer me to comment
right away let me know but if you're
okay with this format yeah yeah I know
this is good the other thing I'm looking
at is Queen to b3 lining and queen up
both with the bishop and the rook and
then maybe later
playing c5 oh that's sneaky but then I
am you know not no longer defending the
f1 square which seems like an important
square to defend right now if the rook
were to come to f1 then I'd have to play
King to h2 and then the rook could go
over to a-1 although that would then be
defended by the Queen so that's okay hmm
I'm actually gonna play Queen to e4 wait
no that's that that's a so video ID
because there is an undefended pawn
right now but I don't know that that
pawn is really gonna be the focus of
this game wow this is I'm really unclear
here on what to do well it's a good
friend I could move the bishop to f4
just to block the file because it's
defended by the pawn and then I could
start to figure out some other strategy
and then I don't have to worry about the
Queen having to defend f1 necessarily to
avoid you know some kind of a
potentially ugly situation there but it
seems weird to do that also just seems
unintuitive oh I think I'm just gonna
play c5 and see how black reacts I like
this I thought when you were talking
about even Queen b3 you were over
valuing the check a little bit because
if he would have ever checked rook f1
without the Queen defending it you do
play a move like King g2 right and then
he had one check that's it it's actually
not a big deal okay
but overvaluing checks is is a real
thing that happens often or overvaluing
attacks just because you're so used to
being careful with King safety right c5
is also a really good move because your
make
the position of his piece a lot worse so
even if you don't win material that's
great and one more note you were talking
about d5 and you didn't mention if you
play it was like d5 it really activates
his Bishop so that would have been it
something to really be careful not to do
so here I'm thinking of Queen to b3 I'm
immediately attacking the rook which I'm
guessing he has to do something about if
he gives me the one check on f1 then its
King to g2 mm-hmm but then well no they
attacking my queen on beat one makes no
sense and then I'm also attacking the
pawn on b6 and if I take it because he
has to move the rook I'm now attacking
the pawn on c7 and the bishop on b7 so
I'm really leaning towards Queen to beef
b3 just trying to think if there's
anything else I might want to look at
not seeing anything in the immediate
look I'm gonna go for that yeah this
this looks very good you basically
calculated the entire variations through
so you're using your material advantage
to gain even more advantage here so it's
a plan that you could always use as long
as you see the tactics which I was
surprised that you also saw rook f1
which was his best continuation I guess
you saw it before too but it was a good
one to see so then if the K if the rook
goes anywhere but the seventh rank well
actually no does my upcoming move is not
going to be a check on f7 because the
rook one way or another is gonna be
defending that Square right anywhere he
goes he'll he'll defend the square yeah
also when you play chess usually what
time control are you most familiar with
well so I was talking about this with
levy the other day I mean and now that
I'm you know trying to prepare for
pogchamp I'm doing longer games so that
I have more time to think in my casual
life you know when I just squeeze in a
couple games here there I've been
playing pretty short games makes sense
yeah I think longer games and thinking
about them is gonna help you improve
more just as long as you also get
practice in the time format that's gonna
be there during pogchamp right right
that makes sense which yeah I'm sure
there's a lot of people you could do
practice games with so I mean now
there's two I guess what we would call
free pawns I could take the pawn on c7
or I could take the pawn on b7 if I take
the one on b7 the one on c7 is pinned
but the bishop could move to b8 and I
can't take it because it's fended by the
rook I also wouldn't be able to take the
pawn on c7 with the Queen but I could at
that point take the pawn on c7 with my
bishop potentially and then if Bishop
takes back I take with the Queen and
have check if not then I move the bishop
out of the way and have a discovered
check with the Queen on b7 now what
let's see if I did that if Bishop here
my bishop goes here
okay well if I take the pawn on c7 then
what right I mean I guess then the
bishop could be attacked by the rook and
I'd have to figure out how to defend it
so I'm really leaning towards taking the
pawn on b7 yeah I'm gonna go for that
and then if the bishop goes to b8 I can
also take the pawn on a6 if I want
although then the you know then that
would be okay actually I think I like
that there was two possible pawns you
could take and you calculate it through
on all of them that is definitely really
good practice and yeah Queen takes b7
was the best booth so this seems like a
free pawn on c7 because if the bishop
takes it I think that I just have to do
that because if the bishop takes it I
take the bishop back with check if the
bishop doesn't take it then I take the
bishop with the discovered at a
discovered check the King would have to
go to either g8 or G or H aid if g8 I
have check on d5
if h8 I don't know but maybe I figured
that out later or I can just take this
pawn on a 6 and then if c6 and a
discovered attack on my bishop I can
still take the bishop I'm just trading
it and no longer defending it with the
Queen yeah I think I'm gonna take with
the bishop on c7 hey yeah the only
remove you didn't calculate was rook f7
so the way he could have defended the
piece and tried to like pin your bishop
it was still winning but just one small
thing you overlooked there everything
else was good so now I guess okay so if
I take the bishop on c7 it's a check if
he defends with the rook I just take the
rook so I don't believe he would do that
if King to g8 or King to H
eight then maybe I take the pawn on a
six or start pushing my pawns forward I
mean I think in either case I have to
take this Bishop here yeah you're you've
been just playing this really accurately
since you moved c5 and Queen b3 so now
it's a question of do I start pushing my
C and D pawns threatening to promote or
do I start moving my G and H pawns
there's one correct answer between that
there is you'll win regardless but
there's one that's generally always
correct I think I'm gonna start pushing
for promotion yeah so whenever you have
passed pawns you want to prioritize
pushing those okay so now I mean do I
just check the King again I don't know
if I gain much with that my instinct is
to check the King on d8 and then if the
rook comes back hmm is there any way to
pin the rook not from this position I
don't know how much it Matt I don't know
if I need to overthink this here but
maybe I feel like you would win this
game also feels rapid but I generally
like if you're taking your time and
you're playing it very well I think it's
the best practice honestly if you have
the time to do it I think I'll play
Queen to d6 I mean what I need to avoid
is like just the Queen getting
perpetually attacked by the rook right
and now he doesn't have any way to
attack your Queen cuz f6 you can take
and same with rook d7 right so what's
your plan now that your queen is not
under attack
I think c6 yes
this a separator separates is suffering
with this game it's I don't think I
gained anything from the check on e5 so
I'm just gonna push forward yeah exactly
and used to you still think I shouldn't
give the Queen away do you know the the
the square role was promoting No
okay well I'll show it to you quickly
after basically if if the King cannot
catch your pawns that are promoting so
like say that you're in this position
you don't have a queen or a rook his
King can't catch c7 or c8 so that would
be fine honestly and also the King
wouldn't I guess the if the king is
close it can't actually stop two pawns
even though I do my g2 I mean there's
really no other move yep you go you go
to fight king h2 but he would have an
extra check so always trying to sneak
over with a king now I think I can win
the rook here right oh well no no
because then he can block with the rook
if I do it sure actually this is a good
this is a good practice for the square
rule so if you take his rook here can he
pass can you catch your pawn on c6 from
promoting no yes so in a position like
this you could just go for the sack now
should I or should I just pin the rook
by putting well one of them is
technically faster but both are totally
winning so all right I'm gonna pin the
rook here oh wait oh yeah no that's good
yeah penny of the rook is actually
faster cuz you're gonna check made him
sooner than if you would with just the
the Queen and the king so now the rook
is unpinned but nothing is under attack
so i thought i play c7 yeah so far so
good and and now we will see you finish
off the checkmate in the next couple of
moves don't don't be so sure
yeah he doesn't he doesn't really have
options here he's kind of just waiting
all right so I think I promote right and
then now what is the right
I think Queen to c7 this this works and
then take the rook mm-hmm and then I
think this is made yeah I didn't I
didn't blow it Wow
a hard-fought wind I mean he made it
harder he made it harder even after that
mistake no I I was I was really really
impressed here honestly I think the
number one thing I noticed that went
wrong um was sorry I
you deserve a ton of praise for this
game I'm just I'm just giving you the
tips Oh things went wrong alright no
believe me things went wrong and your
coach is like okay no not at all
so when you are calculating certain
variations yeah you would miss the last
move because you need to go one move
deeper mm-hmm it's it's hard to give
that advice because in pop shops I the
time control is still pretty quick so if
you go too deep in every variation you
might get up you might end up getting
into time pressure right but yeah you
have to you know you'll have to balance
the time pressure with just trying to go
a little bit deeper well like one move
deeper into most of your variations
would have fixed a lot of what I saw
were the miscalculations interesting the
second thing I noticed when there were a
lot of trades um and there was like a
lot of piece capturing you would
sometimes um also make a mistake there
so for example like the two rooks versus
a rook in a queen right basically you're
trading the same amount of piece but you
have to but it's like the piece value
thing that takes some paying attention
to so yeah I think my advice to work on
those things work whenever like you have
a few trades that's a moment when you
should take time and then in the other
positions you're actually playing very
well
and I think you could speed up there in
terms of how your time management will
work for pogchamp okay okay that's good
yeah yeah
yeah I do find that sometimes there's a
situation that I think is just an even
trade and I end up down a piece right
right and and like again that's super
common because you can like just look at
the pieces attacking and the pieces
defending yeah but but try to look at
the move order for those trades and like
see which pieces are gonna end up
capturing first because that's a really
common way people people make mistakes
now our other pogchamp s-- players
watching this stream now and observing
and trying to steal techniques from me
is that happening right now yeah we
might have awesome show in the chat
right now yeah I should see his DMS to
me on Twitter I could I could get him
kicked out of pogchamp sif he ever saw
the things he sends me on Twitter and I
may do it
if it comes down to it the final Austin
you blunder you're leaking the dance I'm
kidding of course no no how much austin
says about his political leanings he
actually is a suit observer of the
political world I'm and many people may
not a lot of people to quote our
president a lot of people don't know
that he said true in the chat yes Wow
well okay the I mean I think we we we
covered some important ground here yeah
I thought so too
I I hope that was helpful with thinking
out loud
if you have time to work on some puzzles
that would be really helpful
so even puzzle rush on chess comm if you
do it without a timer I would recommend
doing that first instead of the timer
and because if you actually take time to
understand the patterns you'll be more
likely to actually like memorize them
versus if you're trying to go too
quickly they won't sink in as much right
so I would take your time in like with
puzzles it's usually better to go for
consistency so for example like instead
of like say you have two hours a week to
do puzzles out of a two hour chunk if
you split it up into four days with 30
minutes that's usually more helpful okay
you know um I just wanted to show you
one more thing it's gonna take me five
minutes yeah
because I don't want to take you know
too much of your time here but it's it's
the square rule which I think I brought
up so I'm gonna do an analysis board and
I'm just gonna fight you to it let me
know if you get it will it like pop up
at the bottom yeah you should you should
see an invitation okay okay I think
you're already there yeah I do do you
see me moving pieces I do okay perfect
and the board is clear now you see it
yep okay cool um so let's let's start
like this okay um I'm gonna give you a
puzzle here let me just set position
okay if it's blacks turn to move here
can you pet catch the pawn before it
gets to promoting let's see yes yeah
perfect
and and the quick way to calculate that
is basically so to draw a square so
three squares away and also horizontally
and if your King is to move and it can
get into the square you can catch the
pawn so if it's White's turn to move
here
you can't catch the pawn because then
the square becomes smaller right and the
reason why this is important is like say
you're in time pressure and like and
it's a more complicated looking one but
the pawn is on say a four and your King
is here right it's a lot easier to
calculate it if you know this rule
because often you you'll have to decide
if you want to trade into a position
like this right because a lot of
endgames is thinking about what the
final position will be and if it's a
drawer if you have winning chances right
and it I should be aware of what
checkmate patterns if I'm lucky enough
to ever get into a position where I
might be able to checkmate somebody
during pogchamp yeah i would want to
know if i'm if I can sacrifice something
but get myself into a checkmate pattern
that I'm more useful with it may be
worth it exactly because for example
like let's say you're you're really down
in a game right and you somehow get into
this position or you see that you can
get into this position right so you're
down a pawn in a bishop is
and game winning for white or is it
drawing now that I have no idea
yes I mean okay I don't know I guess I
might put Edition let me put let me put
the King here to make it easier oh hang
on I I need to put the King on the other
side I was setting up the board and I
thought the pawn was going this way
which oh so one second let me now I
don't know what's going on yeah I don't
know that's on me hang on let me fix
this okay here you go
all right this this position this
position because the pawn is going that
way
I believe if played correctly this is
winning for white this is actually a
draw right okay
now this also depends on black playing
perfectly right okay but this is just
one of those examples cuz like imagine
you blundered a bishop in your opening
but you know that if you keep one of the
pawns on the side you have a drawn
position that's where some like basic
end games are really helpful Wow
and we can also do like a second stream
where like I'll just prepare like some
of the most basic end games to just
teach you the concepts I don't know if
that'd be helpful or I could just send
you a link that you could look after the
stream either way I mean let me put it
this way I think if I'm gonna have a
shot at this thing we might need at
least one more stream I'll just explain
this oh yeah basically the White King
can just keep keep shuffling back and
forth right cannot kick it out the
reason you can't kick it out of h8 is
because you can't check with the
LightSquared bishop okay so if you had a
dark squared bishop so a bishop that's
on the same color as your promoting pawn
then this would be winning four mm okay
so that's the key to look at yes oh so
that's the key in positions like this
but if the pawn is anywhere anywhere
else that's not on the side so say it's
on g3 yeah then it's always winning for
the side with got it the pawn and the
bishop got it Wow and I I think it's
just been revealed are you Canadian uh
yeah I'm a Canadian American okay yeah I
just I just heard a little bit of an axe
in there oh you heard so I actually have
a Canadian accent I mean or I just got
it lucky guess I don't know no it comes
out sometimes I have a couple E's and a
boat's that slip out right right nothing
wrong with I love Canada myself I'm sure
I would love to go to Canada right now
and just wait the pandemic out in Canada
to be per toda lianas I've actually been
thinking about that cuz I'm in New York
now and obviously like most places are
closed like even going for jogs you're
wearing a mask and it's so hot you feel
like there's a Sun on your mouth and in
Canada has been doing much better so
yeah I don't know
Montreal one of my favorite places I was
actually in Montreal around this time
last year playing a tournament there and
I had it was such a lovely City it's
great it's the best where were you
planet is great lots of Canada is great
I don't want it I'm not like doing this
québécois supremacy stuff or any yeah
don't worry the Canadians are not gonna
come after you and if they are I feel
like they're not the most terrifying
people ya know I'm in Boston so it's
just like a five and a half hour drive
to Montreal okay that's that's not too
bad at all yeah alright good well I'm
gonna study some of these things and
then we'll evaluate what the next step
is but I think this has been amazingly
useful and hopefully the people watching
your stream are not furious that time
was devoted to this no I think people
were learning alongside with you because
a lot of people in the audience have a
similar rating so I hope it was helpful
yeah yeah if you ever have questions
feel free to also like ping me off
stream and I'll just send you like some
some articles that are helpful and I'm
looking forward to seeing your progress
in POC jams I hope there is progress
yeah I hope there is progress yeah
alright thanks so much I'll talk to you
soon likewise take care alright so you
see everybody in uh in Alexandra's chat
see ya bye okay Wow wow what a what an
incredible incredible lesson there and I
I am actually gonna be in recovery mode
from taking in so many high level ideas
and I know that sometimes that phrase is
used when it's idiotic but I actually am
going to be
recovery mode from from some very
high-level ideas and in fact it's the
churning of ideas just churning churning
churning churning of ideas that I am
going to be looking at very very
powerfully alright guys that this is
stream number three for me today so
that's going to do it I love that we've
surpassed thirty nine thousand followers
on Twitch and then at some point in the
future we will get to 40 40 thousand
so let's actually raid Alexandre boat